großes kino passt ganz gut übrigens zu
dem was wir jetzt ja wenn wir haben
unsere unsere nächste virtuelle gestern
monika fairness hallo sagen sie uns
einen wunderschönen guten morgen ja ich
höre ich sehe euch auch organisator
ostern frohe ostern euch auch schaut mal
wir haben keine ostereier farbe mehr
bekommen und deshalb im vergleich zum
letzten jahr aus dem keller geholt
manche sind schön geraten und manche
sind einfach hässlich aber es kommen
jetzt alle auf den tisch haben gerade
den esstisch dekoriert und und da haben
wir den rest der welt zum osterfrühstück
den haben gezeigt dass du unser oster
die google ja also hier ein knöpfchen
das wird gleich versteckt zwischen couch
sitzen und im vorjahr 423 runter auch
hierfür ein großes für die tochter dass
das überall so
auch komiker lässt sich natürlich nicht
unterkriegen von all dem was da passiert
und und nimmt die situation an wie sie
ist wie wichtig wie wichtig ist dir
persönlich das osterfest generell ich
glaube ostern ist für mich ein ganz
besonderes datum oder ein ganz
besonderes datum mir erstmal weil ostern
das höchste fest im christlichen glauben
ist und ich hab ostern vor rund 20
jahren großes glück gehabt weil ich die
richtige diagnose als ich ins koma
gefallen werden durch eine enzephalitis
meningitis
es wurde in derselben nach gerichte geht
diagnose getroffen und deshalb wurde
mein leben der rechneten deshalb feiere
ich es dann auch immer als meinen
zweiten geburtstag
und jetzt haben wir diese corona krise
wie erlebst du persönliche diese zeit
wie geht es dir emotional ich bin sehr
glücklich dass wir im familien und
freundeskreis keine fälle haben im engen
familien und freundeskreis aber das ist
der zustand jetzt im augenblick aber die
letzten zwei wochen waren herzten wir
haben zwei menschen verloren den jörn
kubicki den lebenspartner von klaus
wowereit den ich vor 20 jahren
kennengelernt habe und werden ein
wunderbarer mensch war und dann letzte
woche andrew jack der star wars
schauspieler und direct coach mit dem
ich sehr viele meiner internationalen
filme gearbeitet habe und damit mir auch
wochenlang ans etwa und der war so ein
bisschen für mich auch seit dem tod
meines vaters einen vaterersatz figur
und der ist innerhalb von zwei tagen an
corona in london gestorben
und das ist wahnsinnig traurig das tut
uns leid dass es ist im moment wirklich
eine harte zeit das ist eine ausnahme
situation aber trotzdem versucht man
natürlich so ein bisschen auch ein licht
zu sehen zwischendurch gibt es etwas was
sie vielleicht gemacht haben in letzter
zeit was sie sonst nie gemacht haben was
sie sagen das gibt mir die kraft jetzt
und durch diese wirklich dunkle zeit zu
kommen gerade bei ihm persönlich also
erstmal das entschleunigen man merkt ja
wie viel man sonst im alltag leisten
wirklich unfassbar ist wenn man mal ein
bisschen runter fährt und ich das volle
distanz anschaut und dann das was man
was wir jetzt versuchen von zu hause aus
zb der arche zu helfen ich bin der
schirmherrin und der pfarrer sickel kopf
hat mich angerufen
die arche ist eine der wenigen
hilfsorganisationen die noch geöffnet
sind die tafel hat ja geschlossen und
der pfarrer siegel top verteidiger am
tag über tausende von von essen an
hilfsbedürftige familien und er hat mich
angefragt gesagt wir sind in not ist für
toilettenpapier durch infektions mittel
windeln und dann
um telefoniert und dann haben wir lkws
nach nach berlin geschickt und ja ich
arbeite tag und an motivation video für
die schüler haben sie bei laune zu
halten aber bin dann auch nicht
zufrieden mehr mit und noch ein paar
weitere unten heute nachmittag aber toll
was vielen dank für den einsatz und weil
du gerade sax motivation videos
entdeckst du etwas an dir auch in dieser
zeit jetzt der entschleunigung wurde
sagt wow das ist das wusste ich gar
nicht etwas vielleicht arbeitest du mehr
an einem hobby oder einen text ein
unentdecktes talent oder lernst du etwas
neues bildes die weiter ich weiss nicht
genau
gibt es irgendetwas ich lese viel mehr
normalerweise lese ich eigentlich zu 99%
buecher.de meines berufes romane um die
option ihren oder drehbücher und jetzt
lese ich einfach auch einfach was mich
so interessiert und was nicht den
beruflichen zusammenhang hat und das ist
das ist toll und ich habe mir jetzt
sozusagen per zu lieferservice eine
kleine gitarre bestellt und versuchen
das gitarre spielen zu lernen und ein
super und das hätte ich nicht ich habe
ich noch nicht wer weiß was noch kommt
wir hoffen dass du nicht mehr so viel
zeit hast um chinesisch zu lernen so zu
sagen weil wir hoffen natürlich dass er
bald wieder so eine art normalität
wieder zurückkehren können
ja wir drücken alle die daumen dass das
einigermaßen in not egal wie wir danken
dir die zeit genommen hast und wünschen
dir noch ein bisschen schöner
ostersonntag mit deinen lieben und
manchmal suchen beim suchen genau vor
allen dingen ist bleibt gesund und wir
sehen uns hoffentlich bald wieder leider
haben und und auch dann ohne kontakt
beschränkungen so etwas geht einfach wir
müssen durchhalten das machen möchte
jemand ganz klares großbaustelle
veronika ich möchte gerne meine 80
jährige stiefmutter insulin grüßen mit
der er heute morgen im video call hatten
und da sind ein paar tränen geflossen
das glauben die fehlt sehr und
das erste ostern ohne sie ja dann grüßen
wir auch von hier aus und wieder an
dieser website durch den kosmos gut da